so guys again I was scrolling through
Twitter you know me always going through
Twitter and I noticed a troll account of
me and if you don't know what a troll
account is it's basically when someone
takes your profile picture uses a
username that's very similar to yours
and basically does content that to kind
of make fun of you right so I saw this
Twitter account pearly things P RL y
things where my Twitter account is Pearl
p e a RL and and they have done a bunch
of
content that I thought was so funny
trying to be me worst punishment jail or
marrying a
woman and the funniest part about this
poll is almost 40% of the people that
took this pulse in marrying a woman is
worse than
jail I mean don't shoot the Messer so um
okay and so one commenter said to this
at least in jail they don't take half of
your [__] after they bend you over yes a
woman is the most expensive thing in
your life really if it goes wrong there
was a couple more tweets that went viral
so one thing that I'll do on Twitter is
people will debate if a chick is
attractive so one debate that's going on
on Twitter is are muscular women
attractive and some people are
viscerally saying yes yes they are and
others are viscerally saying no no
they're not and so there was a a pretty
woman that came up on my timeline but
was pretty jacked and I said fellas and
that's always my tweet so they took this
tweet and said bad woman two muscle go
away they also tweeted women bad another
tweet if women are more nurturing why
did God flood the Earth to get rid of
them another one I'm glad I'm straight
and a woman because I'd rather die than
date a
female like these are kind of funny um
and I actually think it's important to
be able to make fun of yourself and
laugh at at that stuff so you know
honestly guys go follow this account
this is hilarious okay so finally guys I
wanted to offer a new segment on Pearl
daily where we actually highlight a top
commenter from the last video so um the
top comment from the last video was
Pearl I'm old enough to be your mother
and my marriage is as old as you despite
your youth you offer a lot of wisdom I
like listening to you and getting
reminders of Timeless truth say thank
you very much to user NJ make sure you
like your favorite comment in the
comment section below and leave leave a
comment to be considered for next time
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt and like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next
time